tu as un cancer ils l'ont découvert hier
ils ont découvert hier lui qui l'a
découvert ma femme de ménage qui la
trouvait dans la poche de mon jeans mais
qui à ton avis ça va aller des jeunes
pleins de jeunes ont vaincu le cancer
même des célébrités tom green le mec de
dexter
lance armstrong garde pas de la voir
vous êtes mon psychiatre et quel âge
avez-vous 24 ans vous êtes comme un
docteur de l'équipe le dr ado il
travaille ici je kiffe receipts non non
maman samantha suis ta mère justement
c'était une excellente en a loupé
bizarre c'est bon allez j'y vais ces
trucs te sert à quoi au juste
c'est pour les poils de mon corps salut
c'est adam
julien je crois que je pète les plombs
qu'elles sont des chances il a dit 50-50
et c'est possible si tu étais au casino
en direct est plutôt verni
tu crois vraiment que les filles vont
équiper juste parce que j'en pense pour
la cent millième fois oui j'ai un cancer
j'avais tort travis de vent comprises à
balancer comme ça ça fait pas très cool
55 ans j'évite fans ce petit si tu peux
toucher plus élevé au cinéma le 16
novembre